-Thank you for being here.
You are making your talk-show
debut, is that correct?
-Yeah.
-Ah, welcome.
Yeah, that's what
I'm talking about.
Thank you very much
for being here.
-Oh, thank you for having me.
-I also heard that
you're also filming a movie
now with our pal
Jennifer Garner...
-Yeah.
-...who I love her so much.
Please give her our --
-Oh, I love her.
-Yeah, she's the best.
-She's incredible.
She's so sweet.
-She plays your mom?
-She does, and she reminds me of
my actual mom,
so it works out for the best.
-Is actual mom here?
-My actual mom is here.
I don't know -- I can't see --
-Actual mom, are you here?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Actual mom.
Yeah, actual mom!
Hi, mom!
-I knew she was going to cry.
I knew it.
-Aww! She's got to be proud.
You got to be proud of
your girl here.
Was your mom excited that
Jennifer Garner is playing her?
-Oh, yeah.
I think my dad
was more excited, though.
[ Laughter ]
-Emma, I wanted to ask you
about this,
because I read this online,
that you're a big fan of a band
and you like to --
When you're talking to people,
you like to introduce
this band to people
if they don't know of this.
-I will introduce
if people ask me to,
but I'm not going to --
-Well, I would like to ask you.
-Okay. Then I'll introduce it
to everybody.
-Yeah.
What is the name of the band?
-Seventeen.
-Uh-huh.
-Now, you're into this band?
How long have you been
into Seventeen?
-I was 15,
so about five years ago.
-You're 15 into Seventeen.
-Yeah.
-And we have a photo of
Seventeen, okay?
This is Seventeen?
-Yeah, that's them.
-Wow. A lot of people.
-Yeah. Only 13, but...
-There's 13 people in Seventeen.
-13 in Seventeen, yeah.
It's a whole thing.
-So there's 13 people
in Seventeen.
-Okay, I'll explain
the numbers, okay?
There's 13 of them,
so it's 13, right?
And there are
three different groups.
You have hip-hop,
performance, and vocal.
And then there's one team.
So 13 plus 3 plus 1 is 17.
-Okay. Yeah, alright. I'm in.
-Yeah.
-I like that.
-I know. It's a good thing.
-Do you have a song I should
download or get on my playlist?
-Ooh! My favorite song is --
I think everybody would kind of
like this song called "To You."
-Okay.
-It's really fun. It's upbeat.
It's got a great story
behind it, so...
-I just like
you're so charming selling this.
It is everyone's
favorite song right now.
Yeah, we love it.
-Yeah, yeah.
Everybody listen to it.
-Yeah.
Let's talk about "Wednesday."
It is the second-most-watched
show in the history of Netflix.
People can't get enough of it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jenna Ortega
was just on our show,
and she's phenomenal.
And you go, "Oh, my gosh,
who is this kid?"
And then you show up
in this scene, I go, "Wow!
Who is this kid? Oh, my God.
Look at these talented actors."
I mean, you're phenomenal.
Did you know of
"The Addams Family"
going into this,
that you were --
-I had watched
the '90s movies growing up,
but I didn't know it was,
like, a TV show
and there's a
comic and everything.
I had no idea.
So, then, when I got the role,
I kind of dove into it,
and I love it.
It's so fun.
-And you knew --
You go, "Well --"
You probably get the script,
and you go,
"I think I want to play Enid,
I'll play the roommate,"
or do you want to -- Do you go,
"I want to be Wednesday."
-I'm not a good Wednesday.
-You're not a good Wednesday.
-No.
-Could you play Wednesday
at all?
I mean, do you
have any Wednesday in you
or are you just positive?
-I'm -- Wednesday
does not come to me naturally.
Enid does.
And I think Jenna did such
a flawless job with Wednesday
that if I even tried,
it would just be a disgrace.
-No! You're so funny.
-It would not be --
-But are you an optimist?
Are you a...
-Yeah, I'm an optimist.
I think that's one of the only
things I have in common with
Enid is that I am an optimist.
I don't like wearing
colorful clothes.
I don't -- I'm not an extrovert.
I'm an introvert.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
-But what you just said, I'm...
[ Laughter ]
It's very interesting,
because I would think
that would be Wednesday.
-You'd think, but I just
can't pull it off.
-Yeah, I know.
No, I'm a disgrace.
I mean, I really am.
I'm a total disgrace.
But then you get to turn into
a werewolf.
-Uh-huh.
-Yeah.
Was there werewolf training?
-Mm-hmm.
-I'm being serious.
-No, I'm serious, too.
-So they go to training --
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah. And you got to --
-Yeah, the whole thing.
We did this
werewolf boot camp one time,
because there's Episode 6,
where the parents come
and all the family comes.
I had four or five brothers,
and they really had to get
them into the werewolf spirit.
So they asked me to come in
and do, you know,
werewolf boot camp,
and I was like,
"Okay, what does this mean?"
-Werewolf boot camp.
So, that's --
-Yeah, it's like --
-Professionally,
people do this for a living?
-They, like --
-Werewolf boot camp.
-I've never done so much
parkour in my life.
It was me, like...
-I'm assuming.
-...running on the floor
on all fours,
leaping over things.
I had to -- We had these stunt
guys pretending to be sheep,
and we would, like,
crawl around them in a circle.
-Mom, were you there
on set for this?
I just want to make sure
this is legit.
Oh, my gosh.
-It was -- I think anybody
who was walking past was like...
-Stuntmen pretending
to be sheep.
Yeah, I love it.
-..."What is going on in there?"
-But you nailed it. It worked.
-It worked.
-Yeah, it worked.
Yeah, congratulations.
-Thank you.
-I'm so happy you're here on
"The Tonight Show,"
making your debut with us.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Emma Myers in
"Wednesday." Take a look.
-Howdy, roomie.
-Wednesday,
this is Enid Sinclair.
-Are you feeling okay?
You look a little...pale.
-Wednesday always looks
half dead.
-Oh.
Welcome to Ophelia Hall.
Not a hugger. Got it.
-Please excuse Wednesday.
She's allergic to color.
-Oh, wow.
What happens to you?
-I break out into hives,
and then the flesh
peels off my bones.
-"Oh."
That's Emma Myers right there.
Season 1 of "Wednesday"
is streaming now on Netflix.